i don't want to sound like an [ __ ]
man but i don't do [ __ ] for the express
pleasure of women man it's a waste of
time it's more it's way more important
to to protect her than to please her who
gives about a woman's organism it's
useless right
wait a minute you uh-huh who gives a
have a woman ever had orgasm with you
when you was having sex do you know how
that feels
for you
yeah but i don't know like i'm not like
in there like like trying to like make
it happen i just like do it if it
happens awesome if it don't like oh
[Laughter]
you remember you asked me don't say you
already asked me he said why why are we
doing this
why not
i mean it's comedy but don't you feel
old what you mean it's like watching
this [ __ ] you feel so old like oh
these young cats don't get it
it's just useless you just i don't care
man i'm not saying you do it to get
brownie points you do all this other
stuff i'm just saying
why not just engage in sexual
experiences where you guys are thinking
of both people's pleasure i don't know
sounded like a good time to me but the
thing that happened is that all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] that you trying to achieve
that you're trying to boast the calls
the this and that like yeah i got the
car that expensive car i did that i got
that condo in miami
i lived there
i got all this and then i got a boat i
could ride on
i got that but none of you [ __ ] you
go with don't come
you want to appreciate something
hell private jets we got you yachts
where you want to go cars bugattis let's
go
whatever your travel destination i could
take you there but you can't come
boys imagine having a man who can
provide you to take you anywhere except
an orgasm but you can't come
even poor [ __ ] in favelas are like i
can take you there
that's mrs
mrs julio
mrs still your girl didn't steal your
girl with another daddy he stole her
with what
they came that's it so you're gonna have
all these possessions all these people
and now the world's gonna get passed
around that you are garbage in bed
you're gonna get
left right and then you're gonna get
more bitter that's bar
i got a yacht we could fly this is
something we could we could yeah we
could we could give you anything money
can buy what about orgasm
turned haitian all of a sudden even
though they was talking [ __ ]
[Music]
yo
all of these means of transportation but
you can come
bars queries are for me
basically ladies to these dudes you just
a commercial you are whole you are a
whole for them to
but you know what this isn't even about
sex it has nothing to do with sex this
is not about like the whole dynamic of
people not caring about women's pleasure
all that stuff this is just a reflection
of one simple thing you are just to
think
yes
you do your job
and i'll do the bare minimum that's it
because things don't have opinions no
things don't talk back
things don't ask for more things just
accept what they get
i'ma get my pleasure you get your
pleasure from me provided and that's it
this is you
yeah
this is you you know what's so funny
about these dudes too is it was talking
about it's like i'll never get sex work
i want i want a girl's best i want an
enthusiastic message so we came up with
a couple of reasons some of the bigger
ones was um the girl's not going to
respect you on the same level you're not
going to get that genuine desire bedroom
fun
you're going to get that transactional
fun which for some guys that's good
enough uh [ __ ] make her come
you don't get better than that's what i
said
but they always talked about yeah you
want to get her best i'll let you tell
you i need to take care of me i'll take
care of them like i never yo it's crazy
you ever had that glaze look in the eyes
when you take care of [ __ ] rough
so to me i just look at this stuff i'm
like do these guys have any good sexual
experiences
are you out here proudly proclaim like
you don't give a [ __ ] about our pleasure
listen if you wanted a sub
you could have said just that you could
have said just that you could just go on
site websites dungeon and stuff like
that whatever and you get a sub because
that's what you want it's not a relation
it's a sub you want to sub you know
what's funny is you kept saying you want
a sub and i kept thinking the subway
foot loud
[Laughter]
oh my god that is crazy
that's a five dollar foot long attack
somewhere you just get order exactly how
you you know
that's exactly what it is like guys we
all know what it's like when you ask a
girl yo listen give me some head and
they're just doing it there's a
difference between
a girlfriend with a dude slicky sell
your dick and the one who's just
you know
you know the difference that person we
all know the difference and i'll be
honest with you i only want head from a
girl if she's not into it into it and
actually good at it so to me it's like
if you understand that why wouldn't you
think it's reciprocal and guys
like
you know when you take care of them if
you want to do any kind of nasty they
are way more up for nasty way more
enthusiastic way more reciprocating when
you engage now people like oh that's
sick behavior imagine sick behavior
being like a bit of give and take
i respect you you respect me i take care
of your pleasure you take care of my
pleasure
i look out for you that's sick behavior
to me when i hear this stuff i just
think it's kind of goofy and it speaks
to like a very me me
uh mindset but hey you know what to be
fair a lot of people engage in sex that
way so it's not even just a hymn thing
you know the amount of people who are
marriages or relationships and don't
orgasm is crazy sexist marriages all
this other stuff super common yeah and
i'm like of course of course you want to
stop having sex
you stop dressing sexy for them you
start making sexual signals because you
don't even want to encourage or initiate
the thought
you still have to [ __ ] them on duty
sometimes but like you just it's less
than less yeah they said
that's like do you want a sex life like
that what happened to just being a
little bit considerate is that a crazy
thing to say i don't know well if you
really like the girl you want and you
care about the length of the
relationship i feel like having her
orgasm as well not only is pleasing for
the average man because you know you
you're unique you don't care about that
stuff but a lot of guys don't care about
it they just i'm just voicing their
opinion
cat
[Laughter]
just that that dude should be a [ __ ]
meme that was great a lot of guys don't
care about it they just i'm just voicing
their opinion i care yeah yes
how do you feel about this
shout out
shout out to the friends
remember say something afraid to be like
let me know this [ __ ] on the bus i care
even the other videos where he's like
men can't sell their feet pictures on
like women can and then fresh puts on
his foot i can i can't look at my feet i
can't and the business i'm like now put
your foot down stop
did that really happen i wonder
what
can i sell feed pictures for hundreds if
not thousands of dollars and possibly
make a living off of it
shout out to you do you care about joy
making a woman bust or not you don't
give a [ __ ] she gotta come before i do
oh
yeah thank you
he gets it it's like she comes first you
wanna know why because it's smart
go ahead
because it's harder to make a woman come
to making me come yeah like i know uncle
i know
i know a hundred percent i'm gonna get
mine i'm gonna get i know so like my
mechanics is easy peasy lemon squeezy so
so you deal with that first
and then after that you do you i know
i'm gonna get mine so let me make sure
you get more yes
i like i like multiple too like she like
comes that's what i said
that's what i said
it make the experience better yeah if
you smashing your girl and right after
she's going to the gym and she can run a
marathon well you hitting it wrong
i like the way this
sauce when i go that's what i'm saying
and and another telling thing too is
that we asked the ladies on the panel
yesterday
if a guy gave you great sex would you
still stay with him if he was a bum and
they said no is that the reason why he
doesn't give great sex is because a
woman wouldn't stay because of that
okay let's flip it
i've hit a few gold diggers in my day
and even when this was good i didn't
keep them around because you know you
gotta pay to play and we all know a true
gold digger would never get in a
relationship with a broke guy
instead she'll just marry that guy with
the whack sex and the wack swag but
smash the young college student while
you're on deployment serving your
country
she'll tell that college student how her
husband never makes her come and you're
the first guy to do it
and since you're the one making her
happy she'll let you drive that s 550
benz give you money when you ask and
swallow your kids and the bed she sleeps
in her husband with
yeah like good sex is not enough to
women man like women aren't like
physical like so why are you gonna do
all this extra [ __ ] when it's not really
like i said you're you're stepping over
you're stepping over dollars to pick up
quarters huh he says why would you do
that if it's not gonna get you what you
want it's like not everything that you
do within the
dynamics of relationship is 100
just to keep her that's all you think
about like all right what do i need to
do to keep her that's going to make her
100 stay pay the bills all right that's
all i'm going to do why would i be
conscience it's like
she's not going to stay
because i was kind to her i pay the
bills
why would i be respectful i don't need
to respect the [ __ ] i pay the bills
women not going to stay with him
[ __ ] just because he's
respectful if he broke so as long as i
got to say is that how you think of all
the aspects of your relationship you
think a pleasure in the bedroom and the
function are like well she's not gonna
leave if i don't do it so [ __ ] it
god damn
this is a minimum wage relationship
this is a minimum wage relationship this
[ __ ] is an entry-level job
into the relationship world
what do i need to do the minimum
requirement the minimum requirement yeah
that's it this [ __ ] is a night
shifter
when the bosses are not around i have
the night shift i do the minimum i'm
supposed to do this that i'm not going
to go extra
who cares if my photo is on it my
picture is not there the daytime
[ __ ] don't even know i exist
hour the night shift so i don't want to
be employee of the month i don't care
yeah i'm gonna do the minimum yeah night
shifters my dog my thing is not extra be
the whole package so if i if i'm the
alpha masculine do whatever and i can
make my girl come even better because
now i'm doing i'm the whole package so
where's she gonna go nowhere else that
boy is good
everyone's different fresh fresh is
absolutely correct
something what the [ __ ] did you say
fresh is absolutely correct and he is
from my methodology is i self-improve to
the point where it's like all right well
you can go ahead and try to replace me
but you're gonna look you know you're
gonna be stupid and it is what it is
like you're not gonna look stupid
because girls talk man you think she's
gonna look stupid be like yo why did you
leave him and she gonna play this clip
anybody we get it
they gonna just play this video and
everyone will be like this [ __ ]
is stupid i look at it like when you
self-improve
where it's like you're the best option
is like all right what am i going to do
here you know and then her not knowing
where she stands with you that's going
to turn her on more you know and you win
in the end like
i don't want to sound like an [ __ ]
man but i don't do [ __ ] for the express
pleasure of women man it's a waste of
time well we know myron doesn't do
relationships so he doesn't keep women
around long term most women that don't
have mental issues will not stay in a
relationship with a man that treats them
like [ __ ] listen i don't i don't i don't
i don't
i don't i don't know i don't think for
the express pleasure of women
imagine being when a [ __ ]
relationship with somebody who talks
like that i don't i don't even
bluff i don't gotta go ahead
i was about to say i don't agree with
everything this motherfucker's saying
but that was
the way you said it
pristine my dude
pristine woman
why was she wow yeah his name is
confidence creator you guys go check out
this channel i'll look the video yo what
the [ __ ] what are you talking about if
you're not if you're not if you ain't
got
who's gonna say if they ain't got after
don't have any mental issues who's gonna
stay in that bruh you said what you said
that this [ __ ] you said you said
what you said this is your hero okay
anyways let us know what you guys think
in the comments bro you heard that [ __ ]